simplement vous poser une question à
propos du rpf parce qu'en effet non
seulement vous avez vous l'avez suivi
vous même vous avez choisi dans la
carrière de gaulle
vous avez choisi d'être gaullistes le
seul moment où de gaulle avait calé
échoué en plus vous avez choisi je
dirais l'épisode le plus émotif de la
carrière de de gaulle saint loup où je
dirais l'entraînement sentimentale était
le plus fort ou la nécessité était la
moins forte du moins c'est comme ça je
le ressens alors il ya vraiment là
quelque chose de très surprenant compte
tenu de votre caractère du caractère
qu'on vous prête alors j'ai essayé de
l'expliquer mais c'est pas convaincant
messieurs c'est pas convaincant c'est
sûr qu'on est pas vous même convaincu
d'ailleurs rétrospectivement est
respectivement
j'ai conclu dans le chapitre que voici
les raisons raisonnables que je puisse
donner
dauman adhésion au rpf et j'ajoute ces
raisons ne sont pas totalement
convaincante comme les décisions
individuelles ne sont pas toujours
convaincantes et je vois pas pourquoi je
serais toujours rationnelles ou
raisonnable bon il y avait tout de même
une autre raison toutes mains d'un côté
je jugeais que le ivème république
n'était pas le régime souhaitable pour
la france et je pensais qu'une révision
de la constitution était utile et
nécessaire et le général de gaulle à
l'époque représentait une volonté de
réveiller révision de la constitution
d'autre part si vous lisez ce que j'ai
écrit à l'époque où j'étais dans le rpf
c'était exactement les mêmes opinions
que quand je n'y étais pas c'est à dire
sur trois ou quatre questions
fondamentales je n'étais pas d'accord
avec le général de gaulle
par exemple quand lui disait plus de
rage je trouvais que la proposition
n'avait aucun sens l'allemagne était
divisée on ne pouvait pas non plus
interdire à la moitié de l'allemagne
d'avoir un état fort pourtant
malraux le général de gaulle répéter
indéfiniment pas de rage alors
simplement il y avait mon amitié avec
malraux il y avait peut-être le regret
de ne pas avoir été un peu plus
gaulliste à londres montrait souvent
j'agis en fonction des regrets ou de mes
déceptions origine
je corrige après coup pour commettre une
autre erreur peut-être et enfin en tout
état de cause j'ai adhéré au rpr
j'ai été membre du conseil national et
de telle sorte que je puisse peut dire
que je suis un des paras gaulliste qui
n'ont réellement rien tirées du
gaullisme et vous avez à dire